while the president appears to continue
to be consumed on an almost daily basis
with the Russia investigation he has
more pressing matters at hand
such as whether his summit with Kim
jong-un is on or off meeting with the
president of Uzbekistan today President
Trump was unclear about the status of
his summit with North Korean leader Kim
jong-un North Korea pulled out of
meetings with South Korean officials
this week protesting joint us-south
Korean military exercises Pyongyang also
left open to question whether the u.s.
North Korea meeting would be scuttled
White House officials think it all might
be so much North Korean bluster this is
something that we fully expected the
president is very you stand ready for
tough negotiations and if they want to
meet will be ready and if they don't
that's okay to continue with the
campaign of maximum pressure if that's
the case but like I just said if they
want to meet the president will
certainly be ready while military
exercises were the initial rationale for
its tantrum North Korea also made clear
it has an issue with what National
Security Advisor John Bolton told fox's
Chris Wallace on April 29th Bolton
saying there is already a model for what
North Korean denuclearization would look
like and we have very much in mind the
Libya model from 2003-2004 there are
obviously differences the Libyan program
was much smaller but that was basically
the agreement that we made and so we'll
want to test North Korea in this first
meeting for evidence that they have made
that strategic decision press secretary
Sarah Huckabee Sanders today walked that
back a bit insisting any vision for
denuclearization will come from the
president and that he has his own ideas
I haven't seen that that's like a
specific thing I know that that comment
was made but I don't think we're going
off of there's not a cookie cutter model
on how this works this is a president
Trump model he's gonna run this the way
he sees fit we all know that you're
aware he's the best negotiator we also
got more insight today into why Rudy
Giuliani dropped the bombshell on May
2nd that President Trump remember
michael cohen for the payment to stormy
Daniels in a financial disclosure
released by the office of government
ethics today President Trump reports in
2016 expenses were incurred by one of
Donald J Trump's attorneys Michael Cohen
mr. Cohen sought reimbursement of those
expenses and mr. Trump fully reimbursed
mr. Cohen in 2017 the president contends
he was not required to report the
reimbursement but did so in the interest
of transparency OGE disagreed in a
comment saying it concluded that the
information related to the payment made
by mr. Cohen is required to be reported
though GE adding that the president has
now met the reporting requirements the
question why didn't the president report
the payment to stormy Daniels and
reimbursement to Cohen last year in
March Citizens for responsibility and
ethics in Washington filed suit with the
O GE and DOJ wanting to know if the
failure to report it in his June 2017
financial disclosure was knowing and
willful the acting director of the
office of government ethics said both
reports and an accompanying letter to
the Deputy Attorney General rod
Rosenstein for further investigation or
at least further consideration as to why
Giuliani made that statement to Sean
Hannity Beck on May the second sources
tell Fox News Giuliani was aware that
the Cohen payments would come out of the
president's financial disclosure and
wanted to get ahead of it by getting
ahead of it Brett it would be Giuliani
who took the hit and not the president
believe Rudy Giuliani was on laura
ingraham show tonight 10:00 p.m. I want
to ask you about something else speaking
of the investigation robert muller
rogers stones social media director in
the news today what's that about yeah
Robert Muller has issued a subpoena to
Jason Sullivan he was Roger stone a good
friend of the president's associate of
the presidents in 2016 his social media
director
we contacted Jason Sullivan who
confirmed at Fox News that yes he did
indeed receive a subpoena wouldn't go
much beyond that though but this is an
indication Brett that Muller may be
looking into any evidence that Roger
stone knew what WikiLeaks was up to when
it was releasing all of those Clinton
emails that
at least allegedly had been hacked by
Russia
I guess Muller wants to know what Roger
stone knew and when he knew it Brett
John Roberts loving the North Lawn John
thank you